so freunde der moment ist erreicht wo
ich mir sage fick dich spiel
fick dich audacity ich steig komplett um
ich nutze jetzt ein komplett anderes
aufnahmeprogramm es wird wieder alles
gelöscht
ich könnte heulen ich konnte wirklich
wollen ihr seht wahrscheinlich gerade im
hintergrund diese folge wie sie sich im
highspeed takt abspielt in vier minuten
ich könnte natürlich jede folge so
machen ich meine es wäre kein
regelverstoß ihr seht genau was ich
mache ich kommentiert nur nach ist ein
bisschen scheiße ich meine ich sitz hier
20 minuten lang den ich zwanzig minuten
16 minuten was macht diese folge ge
schön ich war oft ich erst mal ganz kurz
was ich gemacht habe
ich habe erst mal so ein paar sachen die
ich habe diese ganzen ärzte aus der
truhe rausgenommen und mir neue öfen
gekracht und ihnen die öwr eingelegt
weil ich das ganze ein bisschen
aufräumen wollte ich hatte die ganze
diese scheiß erz brücke in einer truhe
und wollte daraus dann einfach normale
ärzte machen diese waren dass ich damit
dann auch mal ein bisserl was kräften
kann und so was alles habe die dann alle
in meine hüften gepackt die stars ananas
und ich hab die ganzen sachen gepackt
hat mir dann aufgefallen obwohl wenig
kohle bin dann wollte dann eigentlich
meine minions anstatt holen aber
irgendwie als das versucht habe ist
minecraft abgeschmiert also ich weiß
kann ich an welcher stelle ihre garzeit
ich weiß wie schlecht das abspiel werde
vielleicht ist es schon abgestürzt bei
aufnahmen ganz kurz gesehen dass ich
wieder mein menü war und da wieder drauf
gegangen irgendwie keine ahnung was
passiert ist jedenfalls hat danach ein
bisschen geruckelt aber das war ich
relativ erträglich noch und ich bin eine
höhle gegangen auf meine eigenen trip
und ab nach diamanten kohle und
fossilien ausschau gehalten habe auch
das alles gefunden habe durch acht
fossilien gefunden irgendwie 20
diamanten und 40 kohle oder so noch ein
paar andere sachen wieder auf dem weg
waren die koffer tinnen aluminium habe
ich auch noch mitgenommen und bin dann
wieder nach hause geflogen mit dem
ganzen stoff den ich da wieder raus
gegangen hab dann den ausgang gefunden
bin dann nach hause geflogen habe dann
noch mal die kohle verteilt auf die
einzelnen öffnet auf diese acht
öffentlich wieder neu gekostet habe und
das ganze dann zu ende so aus brennen
lassen und dann habe ich die acht
fossilien die ich hatte in meiner getan
oder die chance 25 prozent ist das
damals rausbekommt rauskommt ist die
chance dabei acht sachen dass zwei
sachen raus kommen zwei dna zwei dino
dna so ich dachte reingepackt das
einzige was rauskam pfarrer francis
knochen und knochenmehl dann hätte ich
mir auch so kommen fick dich spiel
naja jedenfalls hat mich dass da ein
bisschen abgefuckt habe dann meinen mann
inventar sortiert hat dann in die tron
gepackt bin nochmal zu den urnen
gegangen und auch zum dino dahinten der
danke an euch in den kommentaren
das geschrieben haben der immer noch
antut ist den ich auch nicht mehr
tainment kann man kann die dinos und nur
so dementsprechend themen dass auf
diesem weg themen das
die da quasi stehen diese sei und man
muss neben dem eis stehen sechs blöcke
davon entfernt und dann ist der tate und
der waadt an tamed eigentlich von anfang
an aber ich habe den haushalt in
geschlagen dann dachte der sich so auf
weil mir jetzt nicht mehr also das ist
nicht der richtige per link nicht werden
wir noch mal neu denken machen
ich dachte ja nicht gedacht dass ich
jetzt in dieser folge machte aber da kam
einfach keine dna soll wie bist du
aufgeregt jedenfalls habe ich außerdem
noch angekündigt dass morgen kommt die
einstündige folge bzw 40 minuten bis
eine stunde keine ahnung wie lange nicht
dabei sein werde
wo ich nur mein haus bauen werde und
eventuell noch ein paar sachen think
us-kampfjet machen werde
das ist ganz einfach weil ich noch
keinerlei stress machen kann ab dem
ersten oktober kann ich die ab mitte
september kann ich lachen weil ich mir
dann eine neue leitung besorge dann habe
ich eine 50.000 anleitung und dann
sollte ich damit eigentlich livestream
können und dann wenn bisher noch
überhaupt noch galaxy läuft wie man das
unter 90 folgen bis dahin ca dann werde
ich galaxy streamen und alles mögliche
andere aber ich sage ich schon mal das
wort wenn alles gut klappt kommt morgen
nur ein video und das wird aber da
dieses 40-minütige galaxy video sein und
übermorgen dann der kontakt wo ich an
der rennstrecke bin und als wirklich
quatsch invertiert zu lange ich hoffe
ihr hattet trotzdem spaß bei dem video
bitte lasst einen daumen hoch da gegen
alle leute die wie mein ohr voll scheiße
dass es immer fax ich gebe darunter weiß
nicht wie es dagegen halten freunde das
ist auf jeden fall wäre super cool von
euch und schreib mir weiterhin tipps
tricks zu weiß nicht vielleicht kickers
construct in die kommentare und dann
sehen wir uns mal wieder